tyler malley getting focused and also
focusing on small detail he believes
that he was tipping his pitches last
time out against the giants
and there it's the fastball that tickles
the upper reaches up and in strike three
call
swing and a miss now he's breaking out
everything
that pitch dove
late in calhoun over top
swinging a miss three up three down all
by way of k tyler o'malley is dialed in
steven boat will be the hitter 2-2 swing
and a miss
fastball away from valley he's got four
strikeouts two men are out and now the
batter is nick ahmed
and he goes down gawking
paint from mali
five strikeouts
we'll head to the top of the third in
cincinnati two up and two down and now
pavin smith swing and a miss nearly to a
knee tyler mally another perfect inning
he's allowed just an infield hit can we
go to the fourth hole calhoun's going to
lead it off for the diamondbacks tyler
malley is allowed just to come comeback
infield hit that ricocheted off his
lower half
pull the string at calhoun out in front
seven k's for tyler malley well he's
established a fastball and
you can see the split the grip on that
split finger back to work meryl kelly
bottom of the fourth now the reds really
have something going here with the bags
packed only one out let's see here
jonathan india his swing with minute
scoring position
eight for 14
10 rbis
[Music]
in the air to left field peralta broke
leg
extends makes the catch suarez tags it
third votto had gone halfway suarez
scores zach flying and another rbi for
jonathan india and the reds take a
one-nothing lead
to the fifth valley has struck out seven
over the first four innings of this game
he's allowed just one hit out in front
swinging a miss
eight strikeouts for tyler malley well
vogue was out on a fastball away last
time you talk about making an adjustment
breaking ball grip so to get him out and
now winker at the plate trying to get
the wrench another run
and that is a fair ball that's going to
be a run
the windmill on for stevenson he scores
winker up to second looks in the corner
the bulls booted by calhoun
and winker claims third on the slide
reds lead two nothing and a man 90 feet
away
i don't know what else you can say about
this kid man you could just flat out hit
now tyler naquin first pitch sent to
center
one out heath and deep center of the
catch winker tags throw in no chance
wanker scores
three nothing reds
o'malley came into this inning one over
the minimum through five but a walk and
a hit batter start off the sixth inning
two on nobody out paving smith
that's a tapper back to maui chants at
two fire to suarez on to first double
play
one six three dp
o'malley helps himself out right here
and
fields his ball
sets his feet makes a nice throw to
suarez at shortstop three-nothing the
reds on top as we shift to the seven
tyler malley season high for strikeouts
nine that came in his 20-21 debut
against the cardinals swinging a miss
a season-high tying ninth strikeout for
tyler mallett o'malley's done a nice job
of throwing that fastball up and in at
that backdoor breaking ball and bell is
going to beckon for the reds best
bullpen arm and tj antoine allie has
been dynamite but he is done so a hit
and two walks in the inning have loaded
the bases with two outs for the
diamondbacks nick heath has walked and
grounded out swinging a mess he struck
it out no ants onto the reds leave him
loaded valley in line for the win the
two hitter in progress and we'll go to
the ninth inning cincinnati leading the
d-backs three-nothing left-hander were
number 50. david bell going right back
to garrett to get back up on that horse
and that'll get the tying run to the
plate it's josh van meter roll to add
second base carson and kelly at first
josh ball deep right field and we are
tied
the former red is back in town it's a
3-3 ball game
josh van meter
way out to right fail that it's 3-3 got
a slider in the strike zone down and in
at 84. team down by three runs at the
bottom of the ninth and he goes deep to
tie it up we'll go to the bottom of the
knife two men are out and now tyler
stevenson
broken back
it's gonna fall in right field calhoun
coming on can't make the play painting
through second he goes to third he's
being set here's the throw home it gets
through matheson the tag
out at home play
carson kelly
gets mark payton at the plate and we
have extra headings e-banks left peralta
at the plate with payment smith at third
base right first one out of the inning
there's a little tapper blandino can't
get a hand on it haven smith is home and
it's four three diamondbacks it was a do
or die for the second baseman
and the d-backs grabbed the lead so the
dimebags now have the bases loaded in on
even it hit him
and that forces in a run
and you hope kelly's okay
he will go to first base the reds were
hoping that maybe he swung the bat it
peeled down at first and jerry meals
said he did not swing the run scores to
make it six to four now diamondbacks and
now rojas with two men out maybe josh
can do something here
that one skips away peralta coming in
six to three diamond bags
so the bases are loaded again dad wyatt
manchester will be the hitter one and
mathison knocks it into right field
escobar is home here comes carson and he
sneaks across
wyatt mathis in a two-run single
and the diamondbacks have opened up an
8-3 lead
how about three in the ninth and five in
the 10th
two outs in the inning everybody on the
move carson kelly comes around from
second base and scores without a play at
the plate alex blandino leading things
off
let's bash down the right field line
that's going to fall fair base hit
stevenson given the green light calhoun
digs the ball out fires towards second
blandino slides without a tag
rbi double
and the reds get a run back
that's one
hard ground ball through the hole
blandino
giving the wave
calhoun with a large lead lobs to second
blandino scores two for the reds in the
ten it's eight five s'mores up now he's
had a rough go of it swinging a line
drive and that's a diving stop by rojas
throws to first and he got him what a
play by rojas to get it out at first
base two down
well i think that's the best play we've
seen rojas make
that look like nick ahmed out there
goes to his right dives for the ball two
men out and one out to get votto up
gets it up in the air david peralta is
there
and the diamondbacks have taken the
first two games in cincinnati they
trailed this one three nothing in the
ninth and they win it eight to five in
the tenth